I'm fine with cats man let me pick all
of them up and take them to the room I'm
gonna feed one on the debated Bob with
nurse them up right quick do you know
hey Stacy
nice to meet you Stacy hit on my DJ
writer this is DJ Issa how are you
what's going on today
we wanted a cat that's like a dog these
are cat dogs dog cats I feel them oh my
god no I didn't see that for real
what the hell I have a dog trapping I'm
sure you guys know my dog from this
traffic and trap he's like borderline
him you know he flies with me goes out
to dinner sometimes with me sometime
most of these guys will fetch most of
them when they're called
how old are these kittens nine days
really yes
if there's some kind of special
bloodline or something that people seek
absolutely this particular cat has a
Vicent in Siamese and American Shorthair
it look like an ocelot so they said well
we're gonna call it ocicat pasal it kick
its ocicat rck this one would be about
$2,000 how much do kicks consider
nothing that 2,000 this one would be
more like $3,000 so okay okay why do
these come out of the same vagina and
costs $1,000 difficult I need to know
that they want this black spot they want
the silver undercoat and it's very hard
to get a lot of these it seems gunk
wants to come out and play here's gunk
so skull that's nice
and he's like well hey dude I want to
run around oh my god and all these guys
come on he's gone except wants the Vasco
how much would you sell Scott for just
seven thousand dollars and said it
doesn't know I'm peso that much so we're
gonna introduce you to a cat I probably
wouldn't accept even a hundred thousand
dollars for right now you know wait to
see now I'll finish talking cat okay so
the only thing about this had to realize
this is she's due to have babies next
week
she's 60% while she's gonna look to see
if there's any predators in the room
that she needs to kill yeah she's yeah
you see my mistakes hair was something
pretty looking like a cheetah this one
was so big about 25 right now you can't
is more than 25 pounds on the scale
cool 35 the next thing we're gonna show
you is Xena she was made it to a serval
and these are most expensive kittens
there are fifteen thousand dollars each
and we have with kids us for the kittens
and this is okay I'm gonna just put
these guys right here you want 15,000
for these kids thirty thousand forty
sixty this one actually would be twenty
this is a female issue the trader 65 is
and what a stud who knocking I'll leave
move nothing the one who's going out and
knocking up oh yes this is one lucky guy
this one is just one lucky guy was a
one-time deal
did he hit all love with just this one
just this one okay what's going on in
that sugar just like where'd you doing
my babies did you come get your choice
your mom sue she may even come and grab
one by the neck and take it back in they
do that oh yeah
[Music]
hello give my kid [ __ ] shouting yo yo
yo yo yo what up what up
traffic noise traffic choppers ransom
everybody knows traffic that's my Road
Dogg so doing this whole thing about
cats I had to act Trevor have to concur
with trap-trap you said cool you know
probably know people to catch I wasn't
sure what these damn cats were but I did
know that they were exotic I was
intrigued about the bloodlines I could
get wild but when she told me that one
of these kids could ranch from anywhere
between to $15,000 I quickly declined
that's just me maybe you something your
cat loves you can state your opinion
right here but you'll be willing to pay
50 or $20,000 for a cat